well good morning everyone thanks for
for coming to the session I'm Adrian
more reasons vice president of policy
and we're going to we're going to have a
panel here that sort of builds on some
of the themes from from that video Sandy
Springs is great is a great story I mean
and the video tells its basic story
pretty well it's been a mule ated and
hopefully will be emulated a lot more a
number of other cities in Georgia upon
seeing how well things work for Sandy
Springs were like hey we want some of
that our county stinks too and so these
communities you know in call it a very
similar path incorporated out sourced
most of their functions and there's also
a few a couple of cities in Colorado
that have done a similar model so it's
it's our hope and and and Lynn might
touch on this a little that we'll get
some more more places to to do this the
other thing that we hope is that it
fosters the evolution of privatization
of city services because one thing that
you might notice in that story is sandy
springs figured out a great way to get
all the traditional services that
government provides at about half the
cost roughly speaking they didn't get
less government services so they're sort
of taken step one in the evolution that
we want local governments to go down
which is to figure out that the private
sector can do things better and cheaper
step two is to figure out well why do
you even have the government as the
middleman why don't we just get them out
of the picture and let people consume
those services if they want rather than
still having the city government decide
everybody is going to consume all of
these services and they haven't drunk
the scope of government they've they've
privatized the mechanism so actually
shrinking the scope of government is is
the next step and the great thing about
a place like Sandy Springs is you talk
to people in Sandy Springs and they are
realizing hey you
what you know it's easy for me to
imagine why we wouldn't need the
government as a middleman because I see
a private company collecting my trash
every day I think if next month I had to
get on the phone and call three
different trash companies and say who'll
pick up my trash for the least amount of
money that wouldn't be true too
traumatic and I could take the
government out as a middleman and it
wouldn't it wouldn't upset my world and
that's the kind of evolution you know
that I think sandy springs is is pushing
in a way that that you can't really get
anywhere else it's a it's a tremendous a
tremendous battle i was up until the
very minute that Lisa got up here this
morning I was on a conference call
there's a little largely Hispanic town
just up the freeway of ways here in
Southern California that wants to
privatize its water and wastewater
system and they've asked me to help out
and so I've been going to these public
meetings and and and and and basically
pointing out look here's here's what you
can get if you privatize your water and
wastewater system because they're in a
situation they're going to have to raise
rates which nobody wants to pay higher
rates but the fact is their systems old
and decrepit has to be rebuilt that
costs money if you want to have your
system continued to function you have to
spend the money do it the question is do
they privatize the system and have rates
go up maybe twenty five percent or do
they continue how the city do it and
have rates go up fifty percent what you
think that would be a no brainer but but
it's not because the local government
employees unions have called their big
brother the big national unions and
they've sent in their lawyers and their
lobbyists and their activists and so you
have this the city is saying well you
know the city government is saying well
we're just going to we're just putting
this on the table the private companies
that involved obviously they're an
interested party so nobody really
believes anything they have to say so it
really is in sort of meeting after
meeting its Adrian more and reason
versus the national unions having this
debate in front of a room like this full
of citizens who are screaming and
yelling in the public employees are
waving their signs and chanting at
hissing every time I stand up and talk
and following me out to my car and
glaring at me it's it's good times but
uh but you know I is so far things are
churning along the survey still say
people support it so I think we're going
to win on that one and it'll all come
out well in the long run and again
hopefully in rialto they will realize
hey you what do you know the private
sector can run the water system maybe if
I get my water and sewer from a private
company it's not you know
world-shattering it doesn't require the
government in order to provide these
basic services so anyway on a panel this
morning is we're going to go first we're
going to have when Gilroy who's a
director of privatization for reason and
who worked intensively almost
mind-numbing Lee with Sandy Springs when
they were forming that city government
Oliver Porter the the gentleman in the
in the video is a great old guy and he
you know he can see I mean he was really
like the engine behind this but he knew
he needed you know he only had the
concept I'm like if it's a no-brainer
that we could do this but how do you do
it how do you actually put it together
how would it work what do we know we can
and can't do and everything and so
that's where Lin came in who had to come
in again and again and help help with
that process along with Jeff Siegel who
who worked on this stuff for a reason
before with lynn and but land you know
similarly with the state of Arizona
stated Utah governor jindal in Louisiana
works works with these government
officials who actually want to privatize
stuff and helping them figure out how to
do it how to make the case how to
analyze things how to pick priorities
how to put the business process together
and so forth so lens going to talk about
some of that Jim Cavanaugh is the
journalist with reason he's he was
formerly with the LA Times and he's got
one of the more interesting bits in
every issue of Reason magazine he's he's
got a column at the end and he's got a
little cartoon that goes with that this
might one of my favorite parts of the
magazine because it's a little bit of
aware as waldo deal you have to look at
that
cartoon because there's always something
embedded in that thing that reflects
some aspect of the article and sometimes
it's pretty darn amusing but Tim's going
to talk about kind of the legal
framework for actually turning around
this incredible penchant public
government employee pension overhang we
have in the US and because you know the
fundamental question anybody who's who's
sort of you know delve into it a little
bit reading a few articles is you know
these pension guarantees or contracts
between the government and and these
public employees so it's not like a lot
of other policies where you can just
change your mind as a group of political
leaders as hell yeah we're not going to
do that sorry because the court they can
go to courts and the courts will say no
you made a contract these people you
can't do that so unwinding it's a little
more challenging than unwinding a lot of
other stupid policies and and Tim's
going to talk about that and then
Anthony Rendon who's a director of
economic policy at reason is focuses on
that sort of the national economic
policy issues playing out in Washington
DC and if it has identified a few really
key opportunities we have over the next
couple years the biggest one being
there's there's a real chance we can
maybe completely kill Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac or at a minimum you know
shrink them down to mere shadows of them
their former cells of course the goal is
you know stake right through the heart
turn into dust like a vampire and buffy
the vampire third so let's just hope but
but so Anthony has as David mentioned
last night at dinner Anthony's organized
this group of all the free market folks
who work on that issue in DC and they
really just been pounding away at this
issue and anthes going to talk some
about you know what that entails and
what the pieces of that are and what we
hope will actually happen and then after
that we'll have questions across that
whole spectrum so with that lend come on
up
thanks Adrian I appreciate the
introduction I wanted to start just say
happy tax day to everyone actually it's
not officially tax day that feds can't
even get that right today should be
taxed day but now they've moved it to
monday i guess to give you a couple of
extra days not realizing that some
states actually did not move that date
so if you wanted to complete your state
taxes you had to finish your federal
ones first because the numbers plug into
the you know one flows from into the
other so even the feds mangled that but
you know happy tax day you know how does
it feel to be the guy there dangling
from the Leviathan you know I actually
always envisioned it more of an octopus
with tentacles and the tentacles could
just keep sprouting out into an infinite
web but you know a few years ago a
reason weekend right after the financial
crisis we had a panel and we were
talking about privatization what's going
to happen in government reform and I
told you then that we were looking at
boom times for privatization and reform
and the good news is i can tell you i'm
sort of you can think of me as a as a
privatization thermometer if I'm busy
that's good that's good for all of the
taxpayers and I can tell you that I have
been busy it's it's happening and as one
as one of our staff you know at the at
the epicenter of state and local
government reform primarily in my work
you know i can tell you i'm seeing it
all around me i'm seeing all sorts of
things you know as one proxy measure i
edit reasons annual privatization report
and this year there was so much going on
that we had over 200 pages of content i
ended up having to split it up in the
nine different sections because just so
people could read it because there were
so many things going on you know but at
the same time that there's a lot of
activity really more than I've seen am i
all of my time I reason I'm still
surprised that we're not seeing more
maybe you know maybe I'm impatient that
could be it but I would think with the
level of crisis that we even be seeing
more and I'm going to talk a little bit
about that so if you'll indulge me I
just want to spend a few minutes
contextualizing this for you and
offering some high
lights and even you know maybe a few low
lights from the world of government
reform right now so just some quick
context there's no possible way and you
know 10 minutes or so that I can tell
you the scope of everything I would
refer you to that annual privatization
report for some of that but I'm going to
give you some quick hits here and give
you a flavor of what what I'm seeing out
there so we've got problems obviously I
just want to put some numbers on this
for you you know just looking at what
the states have the budget deficits that
states have closed up until now you're
looking at over a hundred and seventy
billion dollars and with that we're not
done yet folks we're still looking at
another hundred almost 150 billion in
budget deficits at the statewide level
that's aggregated across all the states
through fiscal year 2013 the National
Governors Association and the National
Association of state budget officers who
are you know they're certainly not rabid
right-wingers they're out they're
predicting that we're looking at a lost
fiscal decade for States take Japan
apply it here in the States same thing
at the local level obviously National
League of Cities is projecting somewhere
between about 60 to 80 billion dollars
in aggregate deficits and that was just
from last year and this year and next
year so really what the way that we've
gotten through this up until now is to
kick the can down the road to do budget
gimmicks accounting gimmicks shift days
of when funds transfer so you can you
know just kind of get across a mythical
line to make the the math work out on a
on paper but really all that is doing is
just pushing the problem down the road
just think California and you know what
I'm talking about but you know with the
scale and the scope of the problems that
we have today that can kicking is not
going to work in the old tried-and-true
methods certainly aren't going to work
so again I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm not
going to sit here and try to give you a
widespread focus of reform instead I'm
going to zoom down into just a couple of
areas and one of the more interesting
ones that we engaged in it reason over
the last year was working with governor
Christie's team in New Jersey and so I
want to give you a highlight story about
that and then put that in a bigger
picture of some of the reforms they're
going on in Jersey right now so last
year in March Governor Christie signed
an executive order creating
New Jersey privatization task force
within about two hours of that signing
of the executive order I got a call from
a former congressman who was appointed
as a chairman for that saying and
basically was you don't know me but I
heard you guys are the ones who know
privatization so can you help and of
course the answer was yes and so I ended
up doing a deep dive with them for about
three months pretty intensive work in
Trenton on day-long conference calls all
sorts of things all kinds of activity
and I served as an advisor to the
privatization task force and so the task
force was charged with finding 50
million dollars they had already built
that into the budget so they need to
define 50 million dollars but because of
the way the schedule work they were
halfway through the year the fiscal year
already so what it to make that level of
savings what they really needed to do is
find about 100 million in savings you
know that you could just start capturing
for that first half the year well fast
forward to the end we did a lot of work
there they exceeded that identified
about 40 I think was about 43
privatization recommendations which
added up to about 210 million in in
annual cost savings and that 210 million
was really only about half of those 40
recommendations because there were many
of them that you could not estimate the
cost up and it wasn't because we are you
know the task force could not estimate
those costs it was because the state
could not provide the data that we
needed to even understand what the costs
were so that's a big problem and that's
why these things are really difficult
and it's like pulling teeth but you can
see there's a range of things this isn't
all of them of course it runs the gamut
through Corrections and parts and
vehicles some of the internal admin type
functions on psychiatric hospitals all
sorts of things but that's not all of it
well first of all so what happened with
that well Governor Christie is one of
those rare breed of politicians who
actually looks at recommendations like
that starts trying to do it imagine that
that's the whole point right so right
now today in New Jersey there's eight
things that I identified just out of my
recent news clips I'm sure there's other
things you know going on or maybe
they're thinking of more but you're
they're looking at privatizing all the
New Jersey Transit parking and all of
the 80-plus
Park and Ride lots and throughout the
state New Jersey network they had a TV
station a state-owned TV station so that
was another one there spinning off into
a non-profit structure the toll
collectors on the Turnpike as Bob pool
has told you and will tell you for you
know forever this we're in the 21st
century folks you don't need people in
boots that you know to take your toll
you can have electronics and technology
do this so that's a battle that's going
on right now with the toll collectors
who are trying to preserve their their
their jobs contaminated site cleanup
looking at the the hazardous waste sites
that the state could not manage they
have a backlog of about 30,000 polluted
contaminated sites that the state's been
sitting on that they cannot get through
to get the cleanup done so they
basically said what if we allow private
contractors to come in and the property
owner could hire them instead of waiting
for the state to get around to you meet
and what that means to put into context
you're sitting on a piece of property
you can't do anything with it because
it's a hazardous waste site you're not
going to sell it you're not going to
build anything on you're not going to
make any money from it you it's out of
economic Commerce so this is an idea to
get land back into economic Commerce I
won't go through the rest although golf
courses I've never heard of a public
I've never heard of compelling rationale
for a public interest in low greens fees
so you know I'm glad to see that they've
taken the state-owned golf courses which
I would I can't remember off hand from
the research but I'm pretty sure they
lose money and now they probably will
make money racetracks same story I won't
even go there and roadside assistant in
an era of Triple A and many other
insurance companies providing roadside
assistance do you really need state
employees coming to try to fill your
tire or you know give you a gallon of
gas to get to the next exit but that's
not all he's doing there's other reforms
going on eliminating dozens of boards
and commissions those you know those
tentacles and government that just seem
to pop up and stay there forever and
soak up tax dollars including the Agent
Orange Commission I'm still trying to
figure out with that or the
commemorative coin design Commission for
New Jersey that's fantastic pension and
benefits reform I'll leave this to Tim
to talk more about but there they've
passed laws requiring 40 in case for
future workers limiting pensions you
know other and also contributing asking
the employees to contribute
one and a half percent their salary
toward health care as opposed to zero in
Adrian and I happen to be in Trent in
the day that that became an issue and we
go down to get a coffee or something and
we see a busload of these public
employees this is a monday by the way
like 11 o'clock bus loads of public
employees flowing onto the buses with
these red t-shirts you know CWA
Communication Workers of America that's
their union you know against uh you know
don't hurt us and that they had clowns
do you remember that they had clowns
marching in they were stacking the deck
in the Statehouse and we were there we
were just marveling at this display it
was just absurd theater of the absurd
and there's other proposals there i'll
skip through just some other places to
watch uh you know there's a few current
governors in the states that are doing
some good things Governor Jindal in
Louisiana we've been working with his
administration you heard about the
school choice in the weighted student
formula student based budgeting work
that lease has been doing I've been
working with them for a while now on a
variety of privatization measures and
you know the good news is they're
getting it done Virginia Governor Bob
McDonnell he's you know still in his uh
in his first error second year but is
advancing the ball on government reform
not Virginia's been historically a
pretty well run state relative to the
others which you know this pretty low
bar but but bob McDonnell has certainly
one to watch Puerto Rico some of you may
have been on the cruise and got to meet
him in person this is one of my
favorites governor fortuno not only is
he cut i think it was sixteen thousand
government jobs in puerto rico
government but he's also got the most
widespread comprehensive robust and
ambitious infrastructure privatization
program going where they've got roads
schools prisons water all sorts of other
things that are out for bid now just at
the local level another gotta watches
the mayor and editing indianapolis
another sort of epicenter of reform
historically Mayor Greg Ballard is
certainly doing good things there now
you know I for the newer breed and the
newer crop of governors i would say
watch florida obviously rick scott is
out there he's on a tear right now and
they've got mass and there's a reason
they've got massive problems I'd say
watch John Kasich in Ohio he's of that
same same sort of ill they're putting
all sorts of things out there in terms
of private is a
and you know pensions and all sorts of
other administrative functions i'm scott
walker as well we had the opportunity i
think i went up there when scott walker
was still the county executive in
milwaukee county to talk to them about
what what they could do with their
assets what they could sell or lease are
privatized and so I've been watching him
for years and I always said that he was
he was sort of the loan guy out there
against an intransigent county board
that had wanted nothing to do with
privatization they were you know Union
sycophants and they block road blocked
him every way but this was the guy I've
been writing about him for years he was
the guy that would go to the mat for
privatization and then when I saw he was
running for governor and then he
actually won was like wow you know I
hope he takes that to the state of
Wisconsin and certainly it seems like so
far it looks looks promising I've also
got my fingers crossed on the other side
I think andrew cuomo is a guy to watch
now i'm not going to say you know that
they're doing anything yet but i'm going
to say watch watch new york and watch
jerry brown these guys are both of them
are in unique positions where the
dynamics the typical dynamics of the the
politics may not play out right I mean
these guys have major fiscal challenges
and they're gonna have to deal with it
and certainly Cuomo's father did a you
know was was interested in privatization
he's the one who coined the phrase it is
not government's job to provide services
but to but merely to ensure that they
are provided so but still I'm frustrated
you know I want to see more of this
stuff it should not be this tricky to
limit the size of scope of government
where is this great d leveraging that
we're supposed to be upon right now I
mean we're seeing and it's happening
it's it fits and starts and it's it's
tenuous but it's moving but you know
really look at Europe what that's what i
want to see going on in the states where
are the austerity measures that we hear
about all the time you know you've got
tens and billions in privatization of
initiatives going on asset sales big
state-run industries all sorts of things
plan for greece and spain and portugal
and russia and many of the other Western
and Eastern European countries major
public sector job cuts you've seen the
protest you've seen what that looks like
it's not that different from Wisconsin a
few weeks ago and then this is my
favorite Cuba private type or its unity
they're cutting about 50
a thousand government jobs and they're
doing they're starting to open up the
door to privatization there was a thing
on CNN last night about that
interviewing Cuban citizens saying that
this is the best thing that you know
could have possibly happened to them is
to have some limited step into
enterprise and markets so if they can do
this why can't we here why can't we pull
off the austerity measures where's the
state austerity measures you know when I
would say that like the air traffic
controllers out there the US
policymakers are still a little bit of
sleep at the job you know getting these
guys to release their death grip on
public assets or public services is
really it is like pulling teeth I can
tell you because you know I often walk
into these engagements that we do in
implementation thinking big things and
then you realize quickly the bureaucracy
in the process is really not there yet
we're gonna have to get them baby steps
along the way I mean unfortunately
that's the case i'll just give you a
quick example state-run liquor
monopolies this is fun i was a part of
Governor McDonald's in Virginia part of
his uh I was on his advisory team on his
first round of trying to privatize the
Virginia alcoholic beverage control and
this is state-run wholesale and retail
of liquor those of you that live in
about thirty two states out there have
no idea what I'm talking about because
you can go by spirits at your grocery
store but Virginia Pennsylvania Virginia
Pennsylvania Ohio in about fifteen other
states have some version of state
control in wholesale and retail of
liquor tell me if that's a core function
of government I was in Pennsylvania
yesterday testifying on this you know
and I in a Democrat policy committee and
these guys were really going to the mat
to defend it as if this is good jobs and
we're keeping people safe and if we
limit access to alcohol then we're doing
our public duty and ironically I
testified right after the CFO of the
Pennsylvania Liquor Control Board who at
the same time he was demonizing
privatization of these privateers I just
want to sell liquor and you know you
know hurt to hurt Pennsylvania's and
hurt families immediately after that he
said but guys you know what we can do
more for you if you just stick with us
as the public sector well you know what
if maybe you could let us do Sunday
sales and give us some more ability to
do more marketing and more this and then
he ended up actually
we want to act more like a business and
I'm thinking to myself wait you're just
demonizing the privateers and then
you're saying you want to act more like
entrepreneurial and like a business
don't you see the hypocrisy here parking
assets is another one I've been involved
in Chicago Indianapolis have started to
divest themselves of city-owned parking
assets and again tell me if there's a
core function of government you know
that is served by that by government
only parking assets I don't see it so
let me wrap up with you know just I
don't I am an optimist i'm a glass half
full guy but i'm going to give you the
reality check here a government reform
is very tricky you know we've got crises
abound if this was your family having
the same financial problems that
governments have you would be freaking
out you'd be doing something about it
you'd be cutting your spending you'd be
you know you'd be doing all sorts of
activities but in government it doesn't
work that way you get the same old folks
the unions and the nanny Staters and the
it ain't broke people that really
influenced the debates still and reform
that's not easy you know government
doesn't expand overnight it's not going
to cut and dissolve overnight it takes a
long time that's it's purposefully built
that way it's purposely built to be slow
and to create labyrinths of rules and
regulations so undoing all that is like
you know getting rid of the thorns and
weeds and bushes it's hard it's not
cookie cutter either so one solution in
one place can be adapted to another but
it takes work and it takes
contextualization it takes a lot of
effort executive will they or the lack
thereof is certainly it policymakers
have to be ready to step up there's
certainly many risks along the way
politically if you want to undo the
status quo and so I you know I often say
that good enough for government work
really applies to policy makers as well
we often typically think of it as you
know the guys out on the line but
policymakers get enough for government
work you see it every day in your States
you do so I'll just lend at this
something's noodling on this what's why
is it slow and I'm getting to this point
where I'm thinking well there's a
paradox in privatization and you know
despite all the abundant evidence
hitting us in the head or hitting
policymakers in the head of failure in
government disasters fiscally
we still are fickle about the private
sector we will go out and eagerly camp
out overnight to go and spend six seven
hundred bucks on the brand new ipad 2
that comes out right because we know
that apple's given us something we want
it's it's beautiful it influences our
lives it makes life better and easier
but then at the same time we don't take
that same model then apply it to schools
and prisons and all the other things
that are part of the public sector roads
you know all the things that we talk
about all the time and so I think
there's asacol chiral double thing here
that we're going to have to you know get
through we're holding two simultaneously
conflicting beliefs that one the private
sector does lots of great things for us
but we can't trust them in government
it's silly but that's where we are in
cognitive inertia in society is tough to
break but that's what we're trying to do
here so with that I will turn it over to
Tim and thank you looking forward to
your questions
I thanks a lot Len by the way you're not
exaggerating about the ability of the
unions to bust people in I was at a UH
we were covering for reason TV for a
video you can see online rally by a
buncha unions in downtown LA had about
eight or nine thousand people and all of
the public parking lots in the area
where almost empty at the time and the
the lot of the staple center was just as
long line of buses and school buses and
so forth and I really think we need a
green initiative requiring all unions to
arrive at rallies by high-speed rail so
I'm a last minute addition which i think
is violation of California work rules
but it also means that I don't have any
visuals to show you i'm just going to
talk about the legal framework for
pension reform not just to help you all
to get to sleep but because there's i
think some interesting hidden in plain
sight details in the history of court
decisions ruling how we deal with these
contracts it's and it's also something
that is of interest to us as
libertarians i mean i think we all can
kind of understand the idea that their
sanctity to a contract and we've seen
with the GM with what happened to the
bondholders in the GM bankruptcy and
what the Obama administration is trying
to do right now in terms of forcing cram
downs for mortgages and so forth that we
want to be very careful when we're doing
these reforms that we don't want to give
the government any newly way to get out
of contracts traditionally the way to
get out of contract is to go into
bankruptcy unfortunately the examples
that we've seen including right here in
Orange County in the 90s is that the
bankruptcy happens and then somehow the
politicians and their wisdom decide that
the union contracts are not the thing
they're going to get out of the pension
obligations happen in vallejo as well so
the thing to think about now is how how
much are these contractual obligations
how what is the
the history of court decisions that have
given us all either the reality or the
impression that these are as unbreakable
as we would think of contract first
thing to note is that that public
employee pension guarantees are treated
more as having more more legal force
than private sector employee contracts
so there's no reason why that is and
there isn't a lot of precedent for that
either what you have repeatedly
especially in California and I'm going
to focus really specifically on
California for a couple reasons one is
that that's what I cover too I it would
really be preferable to have these
things settled by state courts there are
a lot of people who want to get a
Supreme Court decision on this my friend
Marsha frets who runs a pension reform
group up in Citrus Heights says that it
just takes too long at the California
level we need to go to the Supreme Court
once you do that though then you have
your you're at the risk of whatever they
decide and that becomes the law of the
land nationally so I'm going to focus
just on California decisions and what
you see although there are a lot of
decisions I think most of the people in
this room would would not be happy with
you also don't see anybody really saying
these contracts are fully in weight the
way they're treated in California the
way they're treated right now is that
the day that you sign on you become a
garbage collector or teacher or whatever
you have not only you're fully vested
not only in all the the pension benefits
that you have accrued so far but all the
ones that you will accrue into the
future through a series of pretty
cockamamie court decisions but all of
them featuring language that can be
revisited and you know might yield some
new opportunities for us there's the
history of public employee pensions is
these started out as
sort of gratuities back in the days of
the spoils system and of when these were
just patronage jobs that you went down
to the local you know ward boss and got
your job in exchange for you know taking
a baseball bat and making sure everybody
voted the right way on Election Day you
these were not viewed as binding
obligations that slowly evolved are only
two states left that still treat still
use the gratuity theory in in dealing
with pensions and even those states have
not had a lot of luck in rolling back
the what the unions what do public
public employees get now so the the new
model was to treat them as part of the
your compensation package that and we
all everybody sort of familiar with this
that when you that your pension
traditionally as a public sector worker
has been considered part of your
compensation and the traditional
trade-off was always you don't get paid
a lot up front but you get a pretty
nicely guaranteed retirement that's
going completely out of whack as we all
have seen everywhere you can track a
public sector job to a private sector
job the public sector job pays more in
actual dollars today your salary is
higher plus you get all kinds of things
that no longer exist in the private
sector defined benefit pensions and so
forth so that has gone completely you
know the tail has come to wag the dog in
that what we're looking at now is
rolling back pensions you can always
have leeway on salaries and you're going
to see a lot more I mean one of the
weird elephants in the room about all of
this is that we keep fighting over the
inviolability of pensions in the future
when we're laying off people right now
we're seeing all these reductions of
government services are happening
because actual government employees are
getting laid off so in now to a little
bits of the legal framework California
is a long hit the California courts have
a long history of ruling on you know
various court cases some of which don't
seem immediately binding or what we're
talking about and you know some
cases where the widow of a pensioner was
sued in order to get her benefits jumped
up because the legislature had recently
passed a more as legislature always does
in California passes more generous
pension benefits the the probably the
most important case is something called
a pinch his bets versus board of
administration of CalPERS Burke bets was
the elected treasurer of California late
50s early 60s long after he had left
that position in 1974 there was another
jacking up of your pension benefits and
he sued believing that he was under he
should be put under this new rubric and
the court found in his favor however the
the poll quote from this decision was
the employee does not obtain prior to
retirement any absolute right to fixed
or specific benefits but only to a
substantial or reasonable pension what
that means is that what we have all been
assuming and I don't mean we but what
the California legal establishment that
paragon of good dealing has always
assumed is that you are not only you're
entitled right away the minute you get
hired to everything that you're going to
get in the future they can point to some
some court decisions that support that
view however they always all of these
decisions and I'm happy to talk
afterwards about you know what the names
of some of these decisions are I read
them so you don't have to is they always
stopped short of saying you're you know
you're entitled to all future benefits
all future accruals and that's really
what we're dealing with right now
California is one of the few states
where you're starting to see in this
year's budget you're starting to see
problems with funding short whole hulls
shortfalls for the pensions and in most
cases this is still a problem that
exists in the future it exists because
you know actuarial you're looking at
what's happening
and the number just keeps going up there
the problem nationwide is at least a
trillion dollars in future unfunded
pension benefits that may be as high as
three trillion California's portion of
that has been estimated as high as half
a trillion so it's something that really
needs to be gotten under control not for
future employees anything that that's
that gets us into a two-tiered system
where new hires come in under a 401k
style the package is not going to solve
the problem because there's existing
people or retired people and what
they're going to be getting in the
future once you are retired there is
nothing legally that you can really do
about it once the person is retired and
collecting the benefits short of
declaring bankruptcy or something
catastrophic like that you're pretty
much on the hook however until the
person retires there is far more leeway
than has been assumed in the way the
laws get made and it's getting to an
interesting crisis point in California
the little Hoover Commission which is
this great group up in Sacramento like
everything in California it's
democratically controlled however it is
sort of done in a way that tries to
minimize the partisanship and is viewed
as as pretty much as you know the Jedi
of California when they say something
it's there the the real deal and they're
they're disinterested parties and so
forth they have actually broached this
situation in a way that Scott Walker has
in a way that Jerry Brown has and in a
way to chris Christie hasn't in saying
that we need to deal with with currently
working currently hired people we need
to deal with what they have accrued and
what they're going to include we need to
revisit it in the courts they've
included cops and firefighters with
Scott Walker didn't and you know Meg
Whitman didn't when she was trying to
run it for California is a very actually
a pretty its public pensions for
retirement security a very long document
but it's actually more radical than
anything you've seen from near the
rabbit right-wingers or the libertarians
out there
and they have broached the issue that
this stuff needs to be revisited in the
court I'm here to tell you that the if
you look back on the history of at least
California Court decisions and I'll bet
it's the same thing when you look to
Wisconsin or you looked in New Jersey or
any of the other states there where all
this activity is happening you're going
to find a lot in Old Court decisions
specifying you know we were going to
rule for the plaintiff in this case
however we want to make it clear that we
are not saying there's some ironclad
obligation that we there is language
saying this is part of your compensation
package but there is a lot more
contractual leeway than I think people
want to admit when this little Hoover
Commission came out the report came out
a couple of months ago Bill Lockyer who
is now the treasure of California did a
fairly unusual thing for a treasure he
wrote this like six or eight page screed
attacking the thing because at one point
it had said actuary say there's going to
be trouble with our pension system but
in the footnote they only talked to one
actuary and you know I mean it was at
this level was the the attack that he
was making this a treasurer of
California he's been everything else in
California because California we have
term limits but we also have this
musical chairs where everybody's
constantly shifting around in jobs he
has a long history of the you know
looking at former at these old decisions
seeing only where it gives him a chance
to help out the unions and bump up the
the pension obligation so he's a very
impeachable source among other things he
says that the actor that they twisted
the words of the actuary they were
quoting in this story I called that guy
up who you know with the great punk rock
sensibility of actuaries all have didn't
want to rock the boat at all you know he
was saying I you know I want to be clear
but he did say they did not distort my
words everything they said on was was
legitimate this is the political climate
you're dealing with in California mean
you really have a political class that's
never going to make any action on this
until they're forced to I'm with when in
hoping that Jerry Brown will will do
something when he does it's all going to
go to court and the thing to keep in
mind
we nobody in this room will have to
actually do anything about it but the
for the people who are filing the amicus
briefs and who are going to be on the
side of reform when these things come to
court is is that there there is a lot
less reason to believe these things are
is contractually binding as your
agreement to purchase a house or to
purchase a car then we then has been
advertised hope I went under my time so
I'm fed health thanks Tim yeah yesterday
when I came in I drove down us 1 and I
was it's my first time here in Southern
California is like oh I get I get why
you know people like so in the
California it's much prettier in
Washington DC but now you know hearing
that the you know the government system
out here is not much better than
Washington DC maybe doesn't have as much
of the appeal thank you guys for for
coming here this is my first time at
reason weekend and there's a lot of
exciting stuff that we have in the DC
office looking at federal policy right
now whether it's a opportunity to go
after the mortgage interest deduction
some syntaxes of federal trade policy
but the big thing that we have
identified where reason can have a
substantive impact in the policy debate
when it comes to macroeconomic policies
is getting rid of Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac and it's it's one of the Fannie Mae
has been around since nineteen
thirty-eight Freddie started in the late
60s they have been sort of leech on the
side of America the massive government's
Tatoosh ins they're now up to six point
five trillion dollars in terms of their
assets but we have for the first time in
all of it's sort of their 80-year
history a real shot at getting rid of
them and the people who are on our side
now are there not just Republicans but
there's the Treasury Department and even
Barney Frank so that's that's exciting
exciting news that I just kind of want
to walk through today so I want to start
with sort of a question how many people
here on home pretty much everybody how
people think that or sort of believe 30
tree like that owning a home is a good
investment this is this is something you
haven't taught this is an investment
tool this is something we've heard maybe
you have personally you know come across
maybe that's not the case but this is
what this is the case shiller housing
price index from basically in World War
two so right now you can see the the
housing bubble pretty prominently here
but here's the important thing is that
people point to this slope upwards and
housing prices and this is why
policymakers believe that we need to
have a public policy that promotes
homeownership this is why I was sitting
in the offices of one of the top six
banks two weeks ago talking with someone
works for them he helped to write a lot
of the dodd-frank legislation he used to
be in Washington and now it's in the
private sector and we're sort of arguing
back and forth who really whether or not
the federal government really needs to
have a role in basically defining what a
safe mortgages and whether or not the
government needs to even have a role in
promoting home ownership and he said to
me says I just don't see another way
that poor people can become wealthy
other than by owning a home never mind
the mass of foreclosure crisis that we
face but this is and and this is kind of
what he points to so I went and I
grabbed the data and I said okay so
there is this but what about if you
adjust it for inflation so here are the
real prices of home price growth between
the post-war and the mid 90s they don't
go anywhere this is a basically a three
percent or so growth and where this
index say and you can pick the reason I
picked them in 90s there was a law
passed in nineteen eighty-two is the GSE
Reform Act has couple different names
but it basically this is when we began
to get affordable housing goals this was
a law that sort of kick-started Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac and going from just
sort of distorting home prices to
actually beginning to cause the housing
bubble itself so this is also again
adjusted for inflation prices so this is
a real growth so this is after that loss
pass and begins to become implemented in
the mid-90s housing prices double
so historically housing prices they
pretty much stay the same post-war all
the way up to the mid-90s then all of a
sudden we see housing prices take off
but now it's fake and when we we now
know that all the gains that we thought
that we were getting if you you know if
you bought a house in the top of the
market 2005-2006 that's not the real
price of your home it's all sort of fake
and you sort of see this is the bubble
effect and this is the dip and this is
what it looks like over time so the
first chart that's why policymakers
think that we need to have a fannie mae
and freddie mac or we need to have some
kind of government subsidies some kind
of government guarantee for home prices
because that's the only way people
become wealthy but that's not actually
generating any real wealth and given the
massive foreclosure crisis that we have
right now given the fact that there is
three to four years of supplies of home
on the housing market today which is
going to take biscuit that's going to
take a massive amount of time to be able
to sell off all these just empty homes
it's it's clear the evidence is
absolutely clear that the United States
government has no business whatsoever in
trying to promote home ownership as this
end all be all is if that's the only way
you can achieve an American dream and
make something for yourselves in this
country there's a couple other reasons
that we're trying to push into so the
public policy debate is to why it's not
the best idea to promote home ownership
one is in the 21st century we're in
increasingly mobile society according to
the national association of realtors
themselves people only stay in their
homes about an average of seven years
and then they move to another home why
do you why do we need to have 30 or
fixed rate mortgages as this golden
mortgage product that we couldn't live
without if people only live in their
homes at basically on average about
seven years people move a lot and if you
look at unemployment data there's been
some interesting studies that have
pointed to of the eight to nine percent
unemployment rate that we have right now
as much as two percent of that is
attributable to low income individuals
in a home that they can't sell and so
they can't move somewhere else where
they can get a job so we had the you
know in the mid-nineties this idea we
just need to get
poor people in the homes we need low and
middle income families we need to help
them be able to buy home because that's
the only way that they can achieve
wealth and we actually promoted fake
wealth and now they're stuck in homes
that they can't sell and it can't move
somewhere else to get a job so you have
all this sort of like mounting evidence
and it's beginning to win the day there
is nobody that has sort of a strong
intellectual honest component a part of
what their work is that actually thinks
that we need to have Freddie Mac or
Freddie Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
anymore it's from progressive economists
like Dean Baker even Simon Johnson who
advocates that we need to have the
government go up and break the banks he
even thieves even says we shouldn't have
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac Barney Frank
last year on Larry Kudlow show says you
know what by the end of next year I hope
we get rid of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
because I was wrong we should we try to
help poor people this is not the way to
go about this and then the Treasury
Department this year issued a white
paper that said we don't need Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac we don't need affordable
housing goals and we should be able to
get rid of them within five to seven
years so that that is the environment in
which we are in Washington DC where this
there's a very real chance to actually
be able to to move forward on trying to
get rid of that these guys so how are we
going to do it I'll take that down so
the what is the future how do we go
about this was of which the future of
homeownership look like and so this is
so this is where reasons trying to step
in and trying to define this and we've
worked very closely with Republican
policy makers on trying to come up with
so what are the ideas that can actually
going to take should we go should we
take a few steps forward this year
should this be a one year process to
your process should we get rid of them
over a five-year period we've written a
number of papers at the end of the day
the future of housing needs there need
to be no GSEs nope we can't replace them
with anything else they can't stick
around they need to be gone I would even
advocate we shouldn't even privatize
them we just need to end them
privatizing them means that we leave
sort of this subtle sense just like they
were before they were quasi-private
entities that they still sort of do have
government backing and the you know they
could be monsters that come back to rear
their heads we just need to get rid of
it completely there can't be a
government guarantee of any other kind
so there's a number of people there
generally people in the industry they're
the homebuilders to the Realtors the
mortgage bankers who want their
government subsidy for their business
which you sort of understand their self
interest in that but they're arguing
that well if we don't have a fannie and
freddie at the very least the government
needs to have some kind of guarantee
because otherwise investors aren't going
to buy mortgage-backed securities and no
one will own a home and you will have to
pay you know thirty percent interest to
be able to get a mortgage that's simply
not the case there are literally
trillions of dollars and that are
invested in assets as sort of a that are
not backed by the government of any kind
because people want to get yield from
their money if you are investing in a
Treasury or immune ii you're you're
getting very low interest back this is
very low risk but people want to invest
in something where they're going to get
yield back there is so we're working
right now with some other organizations
and trying to draw out companies that
are going to be investing in this market
to show that there's a massive amount of
liquidity we can have a fully private
backed mortgage market and and the other
thing is is there's this this notion
that the government should define what a
risky mortgages so in the dodd-frank law
that was passed last year there were two
things one the lawns hold of the banking
regulators to come up with a qualified
residential mortgage which is
essentially the bank banking regulators
coming together and saying this is a
really safe mortgage and if you have
this mortgage it's probably not going to
default and then the law said if you are
if you are going to originate or onus or
securitize any other mortgage you have
to hold a certain amount of risk and
it's this rule called risk retention and
there's this notion in Washington even
among some conservatives that the
government should be forcing people to
hold capital against their mortgage risk
but this basically assumes that the
private sector isn't capable of
measuring its own risk
people point to the housing bubble and I
said well look the private sector didn't
you know it clearly wasn't able to
measure its own risk it didn't have
enough capital simply missing the fact
that if you're too big to fail if you
know the government is going to come
behind you at the end of the day all of
your measures for managing your own risk
are completely skewed so if we have a
means that if you are investing in
mortgages and you invest in poor
mortgages and you and those go bad and
you fail that yours a way to liquidate
that company and that they aren't going
to be bailed out we don't even we do not
need any rules for risk retention of any
kind and there is this a lot it's nerdy
but this is pretty hilarious that the
rules that the regulators defined a
really safe mortgage as have enough
freaked out all of the members of the
housing community so the home builders
and the community bankers and the
mortgage bankers who all supported
dodd-frank there now terrified because
it got defined as this really really
nervous really really narrow definition
that's going to run a lot of them out of
business so there were all for
government regulation when they thought
it was going to help them and now they
see the regulation come down it could
wipe out half the mortgage bankers now
all of a sudden they're going back now
they have to team up with the
Republicans on maybe trying to get rid
of this all together which is yeah it
goes to show that if you if you really
think that you can have a look sort of a
long-term sense of manipulation and then
something called the tea party comes
along that's it you should think twice
so reasons role in all of this we have
sort of there's two approaches it okay
so there's two approaches of going about
this on the one hand we could promote we
could we could hope that Congress passes
one big bill that sort of sort of
tackles this head-on deals with every
part of getting rid of Fannie and
Freddie with their multi family business
with low income with FHA that sort of
puts a sunset on how long they're going
to be around and when that thing goes
down then we know that they are no more
the problem is with split Congress
politically speaking it's almost
impossible that's going to get through
however we still
want we still hope and we're still still
writing about what this sort of
comprehensive process would look like
because if that's advancing in any form
at least in the house that it shows this
is what sort of at the end of the day
this is our flag in the sand this is
what we want to work work on at the same
time we've sort us tified in February on
a number of short-term steps that
Congress could sort of take and going
about this and this involves doing
simple things like raising the fee the
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac charge to
investors for guaranteeing payment on
the securities raising that fee to what
the market would charge if the market
was actually sort of pricing that out if
you have the taxpayers behind Fannie and
Freddie they can charge a very low fee
and it ranges from 15 to 20 basis points
what that really should be is something
like 100 to 150 basis points it's they
are grossly under pricing what they
should be charging and so there's just
one bill that was introduced it's
already been passed out of a house
subcommittee that simply says Fannie and
Freddie have to over the next two years
raise that feed to what they would
charge if they didn't have a government
subsidy and there's ways of measuring
that there's already the estimates are
already out there it can be done and the
fun thing is is that's going to wind up
driving the amount of business anyway so
even if there isn't a law that says this
is when you're done this is one means of
going about sort of like sort of a back
door of driving them out of business we
need to lower the the rates that Fannie
and Freddie or the size of mortgages
that they're allowed to purchase right
now they can purchase mortgages up to
seven hundred and twenty-nine thousand
dollars which means that government is
subsidizing homes as high as seven
hundred twenty-nine thousand dollars why
this is necessary to promote you know
low and middle income sort of
homeownership is absolutely beyond me
but every hearing there is some
congressmen who gets up and he says if
we lower this this is going to be
terrible for the people in my district
it's going to be terrible to the
high-income people in your district
absolutely but it's absolutely necessary
and that we have a handful of other in
my testimony in February I listed
10 things that should be done of those
10 things aight have already been
introduced into law and passed out of a
subcommittee in the house and have a
pretty good shot of at least passing the
house and they're designed to be largely
bipartisan because the language that a
lot of these laws has sort of put into
place mirrors exactly what the Treasury
Department has said and sort of backing
up where we stand on this stuff so I
there at the end of the day there I am
optimistic about where we stand in this
fight at it it's going to be another one
to two-year fight it at the very least
and at the end of the day there is a
democratic party that isn't even in
Congress that isn't even a line with its
own Treasury Department so I would still
only give this as optimistic as am I
would still only give this a twenty
percent chance that this you know passes
in the next two years but at the very
least that we are in a point in the
arguments where it the the GCS will not
be along around for that much longer
they are not around for another 20 years
we have a very real chance of going
after them and happy to answer any more
questions on the technical side of this
or talk with us elsewhere in to thank
you
you